the jurogan experience so tell me about
your past like
what what about like when you're saying
going through the system you mean the
justice system like
what what about your past was uh yeah
i've been
like in prison and stuff like that i did
three and a half years in prison
for what for assault aggravated assault
haunting people that's weird oh
i'm kidding well you should have been at
my courthouse you should have been
talking telling that to the judge i
would have said that to the judge yeah
your honor i think
i think this is a mistake yeah yeah
so three and a half years for that and
so people wrote you off they felt like
this is just
you're just gonna be trouble your whole
life yeah especially i had a full
scholarship
um i was already i played the year i
ended up getting probation for that i
ended up
playing a year in college at kilgore
june college
and i ended up violating because i
didn't have a job
and i had to pay my fines and fees and
show up to my own
meetings which no one wanted to help me
on to do and so i ended up getting
violated
from that and it was only a two year
probation at the time
justification and so no one wanted to
help me
um to go to my class and help me pay my
fines and stuff like that because i was
in college
you know didn't have any money
and so they violated me i went to prison
for on the fire since but
i got parole three and a half years so
you went to prison because of the
violation of not paying the fines
the the the feeling of being counted out
by the system that's
one of the main problems that most
people have with our justice system is
that it doesn't really
rehabilitate people it makes people feel
like there's no hope
and in a lot of ways it makes them
resign themselves to a life of crime
oh yeah yeah then there's really no no
nothing they can really do to help
somebody to re
rehabilitate themselves you know
whenever they get out there's no
programs they can really
like jobs and stuff it's some jobs but
not really good paying jobs like that
they really need
to really um survive out here so from
going
from that to becoming a successful
martial artist
like and to be and i know you don't
think you practice martial arts but you
definitely do
but to be a successful fighter you've
you've uh
you've changed your future but i think
you've also
opened up a lot of people's eyes that
maybe they can change their future too
if a guy like you can do it then what's
the difference between you
and a lot of other people not much
difference yes my brother
remind me that all the time thinks
he thinking that the fighting is so easy
because
i could do it that he believed that he
could do it i'm telling it's completely
different it's not
is your brother big like you yeah he's
big yeah can he fight
well you can fight in the streets you
know it's completely different fighting
in the streets
like mixed martial arts but yeah in the
streets eagle fight how old's your
brother
he's 31 i'm recruiting him right now how
much does he weigh
about 250. oh there we go
yeah yeah
you can be short and still be the
heavyweight champion of the world i mean
mike tyson too
yeah you know yeah but he's uh
is he interested in doing it yeah he is
but i'm i told him no
you're not doing it really yeah why
because
my brother took ghetto first of all they
wouldn't
the world wouldn't be able to handle
someone like him really he's too
outspoken and he's real ghetto
man i don't know if you can tell him to
tone it down a little bit we might have
i tell him that every day whenever i
talk to him see i was going live and
just want to be
ghetto all the time so you can't be
doing it you gotta learn how
to turn it off and on and he's like no
it's weird [ __ ] being famous isn't it
oh yeah yeah but for you i mean
to to come from being incarcerated not
having hope
into being in this position now and
i mean i can only imagine it's got to be
completely surreal
i'm so real that's what i said it's like
i really don't need to get high on
nothing or
drink anything but it's cool though it's
a plus
you know smoke a little weed here and
there yeah
relax yeah relax take the edge off yeah
yeah yeah
but does it give you more motivation to
keep pushing too because you realize
that what
has been possible i mean you've you've
done an amazing thing with your life
yeah so they give me a lot of
motivations um
like because i know how easy it is to
slip up and go back into
those situations because it was nothing
but a street fight
that ended ended bad for the guy i was
going against
and ended up having to serve almost five
years
but so it could still happen i could
walk out of here
and get in the street fight with someone
and probably be way worse
situation i think you got better lawyers
now
[Laughter]
i think but you're not a you're an
easygoing guy
yeah no i am yes now you are but you
weren't back then when you were
back then i was just i think i had a lot
of anger built up in me i wish
i still do now but back then it was a
lot more
um i believe it was just the way i was
raised you know
wasn't showed that much love you know in
my household
and just the family circle you know i
believe that's what
led to a lot of my troubles it's a lot
of young men
yeah do you feel like um
you have a second chance with your
children to show them love
because you didn't get that kind of love
when you were younger oh yeah for sure
you know
my kids is like completely different
than how i was raised you know
i'm so happy that they're like making
straight a's in school and
making honor roll every uh every year
and
getting already getting scholarships and
stuff like that um to go to
big colleges and so it's like already
it's my life is already
unbelievable as it is and just seeing
that that's like making me so proud
that's beautiful yeah so proud that's
amazing man that's what everybody wants
right
yes what everybody wants is like a happy
life where it all comes together
and i i think with a person like you you
really appreciate it because it wasn't
always like this
oh yeah so i i
tell people all the time i don't regret
i don't
you know wish nothing like that would
happen i believe that
i had to go through that situation to be
a better person than i am today
so it's like raising being raised
without a father figure and stuff like
that
i feel like to me everyone is different
to me i felt like i had to go through
that situation
to be a better father be a better man
here today because if not
then i for sure would have been going in
and out of there
catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free only on spotify
watch back catalog jre videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly
switch between video and audio
experience on spotify
you can listen to the jre in the
background while using other apps and
can download episodes to save on data
cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre
episodes you just need to search for the
jre on your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience